the only thing that comes to my mind is
because I have a Muslim name or is
devastated I will plan this trip for
like two months
kids are excited and all of them some
person that comes and tells you you're
not allowed to board the plane with no
experimentation given is devastating
it's like we would alienate the way we
just take it out the room
this is dear diary tomorrow we're going
to America I'm so excited
look there's a genuine and growing
concern that some UK citizens by dint of
their faith because they're Muslims are
finding their travel options are being
limited I want us to be able to answer
the question confidently that
discrimination isn't happening on UK
shores at UK airports to UK citizens
you